Greek banks have lost up to thirty
percent of their value after the athens
stock exchange went into free fall on
reopening for the first time in five
weeks i'm joined by economists and his
asland is a senior fellow at the
Atlantic Council in Washington thanks
for joining us of course these markets
were only going to go one way but what's
your sense of the scale of this drop my
scent is but this was actually quite
good here in the United States very sir
exchange-traded fund for Greece and it
barely moved today it went up slightly
so it said the Greek market is down
seventeen percent during the last five
weeks that's where we are and this is
perfectly stable so I think strong as
strange as it may sound but this was a
success fabrice they showed vegetable
market has stabilized even if as you
said there was a massive for today and
particularly the banks but that fall had
already had them in the closed markets
so this is a hit they had to take the
timing of the markets reopening do you
think that was right five weeks on that
they had to get on with it yeah given
that we saw that the US proxy for the
Greek market barely moved today his show
batteries was just the right time and
they succeeded doing it and now the next
thing is to pour out of the markets so
do you think we'll have some stability
that we've had a significant drop
biggest in 30 years do you think will
now see the mark is rallying a little
that will do to take it a bit far but
the point is that perhaps we saw the
bottom perhaps the Greek market with now
stabilized and then gradually move
upwards how do you think it'll play out
for the negotiations we're still looking
at finalizing this three-year bailout
deal well they now look at these markets
will this add to the credibility of the
Greek case then it that the markets have
done what your issue you thought they
should do well the basic sense is that
it
vacations haven't been realistic where's
our discussion but about 20 billion euro
will be needed for recapitalisation of
the Greek banks and that was anticipated
in it in any case so it's more
fine-tuning what are the exact numbers
and the measures that European Union
imposed upon the grease seemed to be
sensible most of the fiscal adjust that
is but I jessica has already been
undertaken the big is you know in the
summer has begun to improve sufficient
structural form a bond with the grease
so that my country can grow again and
bam what Greece and all these American
macroeconomist amount is that the
European Union cants some of the Greek
depth my guess is that will happen take
go down into account you therefore think
that what would seem to be a very real
danger of Greece leaving the euro that's
now set aside we don't have to worry
about that I wouldn't say that but the
risk is much less Bennett there seemed
say 11 and a half months ago okay and as
Iceland in Washington thank you very
much short inside this morning